I feel like with my second you just like
anticipate everything and you know
what's gonna happen and you've done it
before so it's I feel like I was a lot
more present
this time
peace
[Applause]
Kylie Jenner brings fans inside the
delivery room for the birth of her
second child with Travis Scott I love
that the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and I think that you
have a real insight into what's really
happening behind the scenes and no no
they still haven't denounced their
newborn son's name eight months later
the Kylie Cosmetics founder welcomed a
baby boy to the world back in February
baby number two congratulations thank
you and Kylie documented her second time
giving birth for the family's Hulu
series Mom's here she's always pumped
and ready to go okay I'm ready naturally
Kai's Mama dear Kris Jenner was right by
her side armed with with all the snacks
she's gonna want snacks kettle corn
on my oh chili cheese okay and cheese
sauce I need a bag for this she also
packed some celebratory bubbles
obviously bring a bottle of wine no pain
no why okay I'll grab something okay why
wouldn't we have champagne it's a
celebration babe we're having kids okay
okay of course she wants champagne I
want right now
what I was just saying you're beautiful
okay I know we're talking about Kylie's
baby but that champagne fridge deserves
a moment
okay back to Kylie deep down like I
would love my true fans to know like all
my personal stuff the baby's name wolf
Webster I think we know his official
name I was like oh I like the WWE but
not long after Kylie announced on
Instagram that they weren't calling him
that anymore wolf was never on our list
okay
um it just was actually something Chloe
suggested and I'd like to do this I like
the name I don't think anything I still
like this I love it I love it I like
wolf I just wasn't him so have they
decided on a name yet they have some um
we have some really strong options but
we haven't officially changed it Kylie
says she thinks so I think we know his
official name I mean I'm not going to
announce it yet because God forbid we
change it again we really didn't have a
name I just thought it was gonna just
come to us when we saw him
and it didn't and right after I signed
the birth certificate I was like what
did I just do
it's a part of his story but his name is
change and when it comes to Baby number
two Kylie's not rushing to announce his
name and she's not putting pressure on
herself to snap back either with your
first baby it's like a it's like a shock
to see you know your body change so much
this time around I don't feel
that way at all maybe mentally it's
harder but like seeing my body and stuff
I just
I trust the process like I'm way less
stressed about my weight and what I look
like and more into the feminine the
whole thing energy yeah and the fact
that I made a baby it's okay not to be
okay once I
realized that I was putting some
pressure on myself and I just keep
reminding myself I made a whole human
beautiful healthy boy and we have to
stop putting pressure on ourselves to
be back not even physically just
mentally
um after after birth so yeah just
sending some love
[Music]